tell me how you picked the suit this is
so fun um covid made me be like never a
dress ever again i was like if it's not
sweatpants i'm going to do this
giving us one good change let's let's
make that it yeah it's the first time
i've worn a pantsuit on the carpet and i
feel very comfortable i mean if i could
have worn sneakers i would have but my
stylist drew the line there we are
asking everyone for one secret about
their look tonight
she asked if she can tape my breast i
was like where do you want to tape it
she's like don't worry don't look and
then she put some tape in there
you know what that is that's that's
friendship she
it's the first time i worked with her
was very intimate but they're in there a
fast friendship um look you know
everybody's loving you on jeopardy could
we see you permanently host um i would
love that i i like to say i live season
to season since i'm about 13 years old
so what i know is what i'm doing until
may 6th and beyond that
hopefully i'll know more before may 6. i
mean if that would happen what would you
want to bring i know we all look there's
such a legacy to honor there but is
there a mark of your own you'd want to
bring in becoming permanent hope i mean
i think being female is its own mark um
you know my grandparents were immigrants
to this country and you know escaped
pogroms and world war ii so for me to in
two generations be in a position to be
able to be a woman and a host in that
iconic role is it blows my mind um and
you know also suits jackets women and
blazers you know
have you ever spoken to alex's family
about any of it yeah i got to meet them
when we dedicated the stage and you know
just feel so humble around them um you
know want to
only honor you know and you can't match
him and so there's no need to try
but really
do continuously kind of want their
blessing that they feel what we're doing
is supporting that legacy
thank you
so call me cat season three what can we
expect well we we are in season two and
we won't know as i said i live season to
season
but we do have a very big ending for
season two coming up a lot of i mean
my jaw has been on the floor in just
hearing pitches so it's been very
exciting for us okay and tonight
presenting um how exciting is it to be
like getting out and getting up on an
award stage i mean i haven't even really
been to the supermarket so this is a lot
um it's
it's a lot
but it's very exciting and um i've never
presented so it's really exciting and i
i won twice a critic's choice award so i
feel like this is these are my people
and i'm very glad to um to get to
present